estelle farges bonjour est ce qu'il y a
du monde aujourd'hui sur le marché
saint-eustache et at il été aménagé pour
faire respecter les consignes sanitaires
oui puis à relire un petit peu de monde
ce matin ici au marché à saint-eustache
où je me trouve ici est des dispositions
ont été prises pour que les mesures
barrières et les consignes sanitaires
soient respectés alors justement on va
vous montrer avec nicolas coupée sur ces
images nicolas couper des instructions
ont été affichés comme celle ci un petit
peu partout sur tous les stands des
affiches qui rappellent eh bien eh les
mesures barrières à respecter et puis on
va rejoindre à elisabeth qui est une
exposante de fruits et légumes bonjour
elizabeth alors expliquez nous quelle
quelles sont les dispositions que vous
avez mises en place pour déjà à mettre
des gants pour servir les légumes et on
a mis une barrière film pour éviter tout
ce qui est bactéries et des cagettes
tous les maîtres pour que les gens
respectent le à m de distance entre
chaque client marquage au sol par
rapport aux concessionnaires qui font
très bien ce qu'il faut pour qu'on soit
nous mêmes aussi en sécurité ainsi que
les clients donc voilà
c'est très difficile parce qu'il faut
qu'on puisse venir il faut qu'on puisse
se charger il faut qu'on puisse ramener
ce qu'il faut aux personnes pour qu'ils
puissent aussi avoir de quoi manger est
un minimum pour les personnes âgées qui
n'ont pas de forcément d'imprimantes
pour imprimer leurs documents de sortie
et venir faire leurs petites courses ou
même patienter dans les grandes surfaces
venir faire leurs petites courses
quotidiennes et leurs petites sorties
elizabeth pour ce témoignage voilà vous
l'avez entendu pierre sur ce marché ici
à saint-eustache et bien des
dispositions ont donc été prises pour
que les mesures barrières soient
respectés et feed qu'on s'est toujours
concernant à la sécurité on a vu aussi
des agents de la sécurité de la mairie
de paris a patrouillé pour faire en
sorte et bien que ces mesures barrières
soient respectés merci à beaucoup
estelle farges en direct du marché
saint-eustache à paris sia